do you remember in 500 days of summer
when Joseph gordon-levitt's character
alluded to other romantic comedies that
were made that gave couples a false idea
of what love is this is not one of those
movies like crazy stars Anton Yelchin
Felicity Jones and Jennifer Lawrence
it's about a young couple that meet and
fall in love until her immigration visa
expires and she's forced to moved back
to the United Kingdom and they're
separated because of this strange law
because of that this couple goes through
a lot of hardships a lot of problems
this film is very similar to Blue
Valentine a film that I loved it doesn't
hold back it doesn't fake it it doesn't
make it seem long glassy or Hollywood
eyes it's very good in a way to fix that
I need the idea of it the baby and me
also really good about this movie is the
performances Anton Yelchin is very good
Felicity Jones also is excellent in this
film Jennifer Lawrence doesn't have a
very big part but what she does
contribute to the film is really good
the film accurately depicts what a
couple would go there in a long-distance
relationship and the troubles of that
and how that can create a serious strain
on a relationship that just seems so
realistic that's really the plus of this
movie it's not all glamorous and Larry
happy it's not a date movie might look
at it a movies no it's not a big movie
at all the style the way this film was
directed was very beneficial for it it
was very similar to Blue Valentine you
know a lot of long takes camera just
observing various conversations I made
it seem kind of like you were
eavesdropping on this couples
relationship have you been doing waiting
for you actually party it'd be easier if
you could see other people when we're
not together the only issue I had with
this film was that it jumps time gaps
very often and doesn't tell you how much
time has gone by and that's not
necessarily the problem the problem is
there's a little bit of information that
seems really crucial to know about what
has happened in between these time
periods that you don't really find out I
would have liked it to have been a
little more clear so I can understand
where the characters heads were and if I
was given just a little bit more
information in regards to some of these
time gap jumps that happen later in the
film it would have been a little easier
for me to understand the motivations of
the characters I thought I understood it
but I didn't not really
this is a really excellent film a really
emotionally invested film one that I
felt like I was definitely part of and I
could understand where this couple was
and I wanted to know what was gonna
happen and I felt for them and so I'm
going to give like crazy in a - I need
smudges of it the vegan s of it the idea
of it
if you liked this review you can
subscribe to my channel and get stuck my
knives